- So wait, how long did it take you
to swim to the oil derrick?
- Uh you know t's just
a rough guesstimate,
but you know the sun went down
and by the time the coast guard was called
they'll get there in
like four to five hours,
and I'm just wearing nothing but a t-shirt
and a pair of shorts.
- And it's cold!
- And yes the water is cold and you know,
I've never been really
super religious in my life,
but I looked up at the sky,
and I cry every time.
[laughs]
And I looked up and I said,
"God, you know I'm sorry for
all these stupid human things
I did in my life and I hope
that you can forgive me."
and it wasn't about me anymore
I just I asked him, I said,
"Will you please take care of my family?"
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- "And my kids and..."
- Oh, we need to give him a hug.
- [Kelly] Yeah, Yeah, wait, wait, wait,
oh yeah, wait like a group
hug, like a group hug,
like a group hug.
and a tissue, yeah here you go.
Yeah, wow.
- And you're here, and you're here.